Чи доживе ця бджола до осені - невідомо.
Серед київських пасічників ширяться сунмі новини -
в Україні масово гинуть бджоли.
Пасічники переконані: усе через аграріїв,
які оброблять поля небезпечними хімікатами.
Неонекатеноїди, які заборонені в вже багатьох країнах Євросоюзу,
і звичайно, ці дешеві китайські препарати,
вони теж повинні взяти їх під контроль.
Сергій Терентьєв займається бджолярством вже 40 років.
Щосезону, коли починали цвісти медоносні рослини, такі,
як гречка чи соняшник, він вивозив свої вулики в поле.
Останні роки ця рутина перетворилась на російську рулетку:
попередять фермери про обробку полів смертоносними хімікатами чи ні.
Осінню може так статись, що залишається мед,
оцей пилок, розплід і все.
А бджіл немає. Пропадають, або злітають.
Це тому що хімія.
Навідміну від минулого року, коли на отруєння бджіл
скаржились у шістьох областях України,
цього року про це заговорили пасічники по всій країні.
Тетяна Сушко зі Спілки пасічників отримує обурені звернення
по кілька разів на день.
Каже, особливо значні втрати на Дніпропетровщині,
де загинули від 5 до 15 тисяч бджолородин.
Собівартість втрат тут оцінють в 45 мільйонів гривень.
Весни практично її не було, і дуже швидко зацвіли
медодайні культури, і був період,
коли бджолам не було що їсти,
і вони полетіли на оброблені поля горохам.
Неонекатеноїди мають солодкуватий запах
і тому бджоли летять на них, вони сприймають їх як пилок.
Сезон лише почався і якщо оприскування шкідливими хімікатами
на полях не припиниться, це може мати серйозні наслідки для усієї галузі.
Адже Україна належить до трійки світових лідерерів з експорту меду.
Минулого року було продано понад 68 тисяч тонн.
Отруєння бджіл лише на Дніпропетровщині
вже призвело до недозбору кількох тонн меду.
Утім, від вимирання бджіл страждають і самі винуватці отруєнь.
Агровиробники, вони ще до кінця не зрозуміли, що
це втрата не тільки бджолярів на бдожолах,
це втрата їхнього врожаю.
Тому що опилювання їхніх монофільних культур
на 30% віднімається врожайність.
Без бджіл їм теж нікуди.
Нині пасічники вимагають не лише розслідування випадків отруєння,
але й заборони використання небезпечних для бджіл пестицидів.
Так, як це відбулось в Європейському Союзі
після протестів екологів та пасічників.
Сергій Терентьєв втрати оцінює не лише в гривнях чи кілограмах меду.
Як селекціонер він розуміє, що відновлювати
кількість домашніх бджолородин людина зможе.
Наприклад, щосезону він виводить до тисячі бджоломаток.
Утім невідмомо, як вплине на екосистему вимирання
диких бджіл та інших комах-запліднювачів.
Окрема, недосліджена поки тема -
якість потравлених хімією рослин, які потім вживають самі українці.